aznavour est de retour après trois ans
de séjour et de gala à l'étranger il
revient chanter à paris avec neuf
chansons nouvelles et quelques-unes les
1000 ancienne qu'il a écrite se sentent
toujours avec plaisir et dans
différentes villes est naturellement
avec un plaisir un petit peu plus subtil
à paris qui est la ville qui m'a nommé
début en fait la ville qui m'a connu en
premier et surtout une chose importante
c'est que je chante en français
à part une chance aux gens qu'ils
foulent tour de chant en français qui
est très difficile je reviens à la
langue française que la plupart du temps
sur les mêmes chansons de l'eau chaude
soit en anglais soit un italien sont
espagnols oui justement y allons y
allons vous j'avais beaucoup chanté en à
l'étranger ces derniers temps leurs
produits d'exportation est ce que c'est
le hasard des contrats ou est ce que
c'est votre volonté de chanter à
l'étranger ah non ça a été ma volonté
maintenant ce sont les contrats c'est à
dire que j'ai tout fait pour en faire
une carrière internationale
parce que si vous voulez j'ai comme tous
les artistes j'ai toujours j'ai une
grosse tête ce qu'on appelle une recette
non lieu de l'avoir vis-à-vis des gens
parce que je trouve que c'est pas bien
avant la grosse tête vous avez déjà j'ai
eu la grosse tête vis-à-vis de moi-même
je me suis dit je suis une grosse
vedette
je dois pouvoir aller chanter dans notre
pays mais vous avez boudé un petit peu
le public français je n'ai jamais boudé
le public français d'ailleurs je recule
raison de le faire il lui jamais boudé
monsieur dans le temps et dans les
carrières artistiques qui ont plus de 20
ans il ya la carrière un petit peu en
dents de scie ce qui est tout à fait
normal je dois dire je dois l'avouer
avec grand plaisir le public français ne
m'a jamais accordé la dent de scie au
contraire ce qui n'est pas difficile
d'être chanteur est de rester vedette
aujourd'hui
non ce qui est difficile c'est évident
c'est de rester chanteur finalement être
en vedette c'est plus facile que les
deux chanteurs à l'heure actuelle c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui avec un disque
avec une chanson je ne jette pas la
pierre je constate simplement avec une
chanson on peut devenir une vedette
ce qui est difficile c'est de continuer
à rester un artiste et de tenir de
pouvoir faire de la scène mais ce que
les problèmes douaniers que vous venez
d'avoir ne vous incite pas à chanter
ailleurs qu'en france
écoutez on a déjà prêté beaucoup de
paroles que je n'ai pas prononcés
la seule chose que je peux je peux dire
et avoué sais que j'ai un problème
douanier
en dehors de ça je n'ai pas de
commentaire à faire n'ai pas du tout
l'intention de quitter de ne plus
revenir en france pour chanter à côté de
toute manière je suis en france pour
chanter malgré mes problèmes douaniers
parce que je ne dis pas je n'y aurais
jamais chanté en france serait ce serait
d'une part de match pour moi même et
ensuite ce sera embêtant pour le public
qui a l'habitude de me suivre et qui m'a
si vous voulez porter où je suis même si
on avait ceux ci la recette
je viendrai chanter en france et de
toute manière je ne vois pas pourquoi on
saisir et la recette parce que si vous
parliez tout à l'heure de fils justement
l'argent que je viendrais l'olympien
père à son impôt en france mais de toute
manière quoi qu'il en soit il met en
sable il est impensable que je ne vienne
pas chanter en france pour le public
français